what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar and today i have a huge
demonstrator video for you where i will
be going over all 16 breath styles and
ranking them from weakest to strongest
if you do enjoy seeing these
demonstrator videos on the channel and
want to keep them coming channel the hot
shower within and smash that like button
with no mercy remember smashing his
hashtag energy and passing his muzan
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss your
regular dose of demonstrator content and
lastly as you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos on all the hashira demon
moons and much more link to that is in
the description and now without further
ado let's jump into its spoilers and all
let's make some things clear from the
get-go we are judging the breath style
here not the users of the breath style
for instance tanjiro used sun breathing
the strongest form against rui yet
muichiro the missed hashira could have
wrecked tundra beyond belief at that
point in the story despite the fact that
misbreathing is weaker than sun
breathing so just because one character
is stronger than another does not mean
their breathing style is automatically
stronger the reason people strayed from
sun breathing and develop their own
styles is because those styles bring out
their personal abilities the most for
instance shinobu is stronger using
insect style than she would be using any
other style because the other stronger
breath styles wouldn't match her
personal abilities and strength so well
since she can't even cut a demon's head
off all those styles that rely on that
will be useless to her no matter how
strong they are now let's get into the
story where the idea of one breath style
being stronger than another is brought
up because it didn't have to be it could
have been one of those situations where
commandment is not necessarily stronger
than a gallic gun just different in
other words every breath style could
have been more or less potentially equal
just different but it's made clear that
this is not the case when goku's dad
tells us about the fact that sun
breathing is the first and strongest
breathing technique he tells us that all
other breathing techniques are merely
variations all those styles are nothing
more than imitations of sun breathing
there are lesser forms that copied sun
breathing and although rengoku's dad is
a very pessimistic dude and takes this
too far starting to think that if you're
not a sun breather then you are pretty
much useless there is still truth to his
initial info about sun breathing being
the strongest breath in upper moon one
kokushibo's backstory it's once more
explained that no one could match
yorichi the sun breather and so to suit
each person's skills and capabilities
yorichi changed the breathing technique
as he taught thus techniques derived
from sun breathing came one after the
other the way i look at it is this the
strongest sun breather who perfected his
breathing style would be stronger than
the strongest stone breather who
perfected his breathing style but that
doesn't mean anyone who can use sun
breathing is automatically stronger than
anyone who can use stone breathing using
this information that comes directly
from multiple places in the story we can
start to position the breathing style
strengths in relation to one another if
water is inferior to sun breathing
because it is an imitation of sun
breathing then flower breathing is
inferior to water breathing because it
is an imitation of water breathing which
is in turn an imitation of sun breathing
and so on using this logic we can create
levels of breathing and i created five
levels that are applicable based on the
information we get from the demon slayer
story there are 16 breath styles that
we'll look at for the purposes of this
video that will all fall between level 5
the weakest and level 1 the strongest
and it's not a big spoiler to say that
sun breathing will be level 1 the
strongest breathing style so we are
going to work up to it from level 5. in
some cases there will be multiple
breathing styles in one level and in
those cases you can assume they're all
relatively equal nevertheless i may
mention one that i personally prefer or
lean towards for one reason or another
but yeah let's get into level 5. level 5
contains the breath styles that are
three times removed from sun breathing
aka they are an imitation of an
imitation of an imitation of sun
breathing out of the known breath styles
insect breathing is the only one that
fits the bill insect breathing comes
from flower breathing which comes from
water breathing which comes from sun
breathing shinobu the insect pillar is
the only known user of insect breathing
and she created it in order to
compensate for the fact that she doesn't
have the strength to cut off a demon's
head shinobu used a modified lighter
blade that allows her to quickly stab
and inject her demon opponents with
lethal amounts of wisteria flower poison
one of her standout attacks is insect
breathing dance of the centipede
hundred-legged zigzag this attack is so
fast that upper moon 2 dolma couldn't
even keep up with it shinobu was able to
stab his neck but unfortunately this was
not enough to kill him so yeah this
style's especially fast to reflect
shinobu's lightweight and light sword
but lacks the killing power to finish
off especially strong demons level four
contains breath styles that are two
times removed from sun breathing there
are actually six breath styles in this
category and as i mentioned we can
pretty much view them as being on equal
footing but there are some specific
attacks from certain breath styles that
stand out to me as being especially
awesome and i'll get into them soon
enough let's start with sound breathing
which comes from thunder breathing it's
a breath style created by tangent uzui
the sound hashira tengen's style is
characterized by his unique dual
nichiren cleavers and his anti-demon
bombs it's definitely a flashy style but
it was not enough for him to beat upper
moon's 6-gutaro on his own notably the
breath style is associated with tengen's
musical score technique which allows him
to analyze combat maneuvers to the point
where he can read them like sheet music
it takes time but eventually he can
convert the rhythm of enemies attacks
into sound and the fight into a song he
hears repeated phrases and can attack
between beats and during the rests
dancing with his opponent this implies
if he survives long enough he'll be
stronger when his analysis clicks into
place unfortunately he has to survive
long enough and against gutaro by the
time this technique clicked the poison
in his body had him at his limit just
blocking the enemy's attacks next breath
style number three beast breathing which
branches off from wind breathing inosuke
the boar face girly face demon slayer
himself invented this breathing style
it's characterized by dual chipped
blades and animal-like unexpected
movements the styles the ops are refined
and that often works for inosuke inosuke
does stuff like dislocate his joints to
increase the range of his attacks and
his insane flexibility that he employs
in battle is so unique that doma doesn't
notice it when he takes back hanno's
sword from him one of my favorite
attacks that captures inosuke's insane
but awesome style is beast breathing
sudden throwing strike who else would
have a form that includes just whipping
your swords at someone what makes it
even more awesome is that this move is
the final one that helps push kano's
blade into upper moon to doma's rotting
neck which finishes him off once and for
all another interesting thing is how
inosuke incorporates his sense of touch
into his fighting style allowing him to
send subtle changes in the air or to
even use seventh form spatial awareness
to identify the position of enemy demons
across a large wooded area breath style
number four also branches off from wind
breathing misbreathing is used by the
mist hashina muichiro tokito an
especially cool move is misbreathing
seventh form obscuring clouds this form
is the personal creation of our
extremely talented muichiro it allows
him to appear as if he's shrouded in
mist from upper moon 5's perspective it
seems like he's constantly disappearing
before the upper moon can reach him
until muichiro finally slices off his
head and puts him out of his misery it's
explained that this technique uses
widely fluctuating speed to confuse
one's opponent when you show yourself
you move as slow as a turtle but when
you're hidden you move in the blink of
an eye we're told its top speed is even
faster than upper moon 5. keep in mind
at this point someone beating an upper
moon by themselves was unheard of and
muichiro did it using this self-created
technique very cool and muichiro is a
great example of someone who is stronger
than many people who use arguably
stronger breath styles for instance keep
in mind murata uses water breathing
breath style number five is love
breathing which branches off from flame
breathing fun story meets where you
first learn flame breathing from rengoku
before going on to create her own breath
style love breathing some unique aspects
of this style is that incorporates
mitsuri's superhuman flexibility and a
whip-like sword that pretty much no one
but her could use without getting hurt
the whip-like sword increases her range
significantly also because her blade is
extremely thin and flexible and because
of her own flexibility and incredible
range of motion the narrator tells us
that the speed of her techniques
surpasses even sound hashtag tang and
oozoies her breath style allowed her to
hold off the strongest clone of upper
moon 4 long enough for tanjuro to deal
with the real body and she used her
breathing style to help during the final
fight against muzon although she was the
first out of her sanemi giu iguro and
gyome to be temporarily taken out of the
fight by muzon this may have less to do
with love breathing than it has to do
with mitsuri but she's also super strong
her muscle density is eight times that
of a normal person meaning she'd look
very jacked if her muscles reflected her
power keep in mind she was able to rip
off muzon's arm at one point to muzon's
shock this strength obviously lets her
handle her blade better but it's cool
how if need be she can even resort to
kicking butt bare handed breath style
number six is serpent breathing which
branches off from water breathing it's
yet another case where a person in this
case igor the serp and hashira create a
new style to match their personal
strengths igurus style is characterized
by a twisted serpent-like blade this
style includes twists and turns that are
similar to that of the snakes and just
as gey's sword swings are depicted by
waves of water iguros take the form of a
snake it's notable that iguro is singled
out by the mangaka as one of the
physically weaker swordsmen among the
hashira only shinobu ranked lower it's
impressive to see how well serpent style
lets him fight though because he is
undoubtedly one of the best fighters in
my view in extreme circumstances if he
loses his vision he can use his friend
snake kaburamaru to guide him and in
this way he can still use the serpent
breathing style effectively breath style
number seven the final level four
breathing style is flower breathing
which branches off from water breathing
as well flower breathing was used by the
former flower hashirakana ecocho and
then by kano the style is associated
with grace agility and enhanced visual
powers a standout form is flower
breathing final form vermilion eye it
puts so much pressure on kano's already
special eyes that they turn red from the
blood and the ability can lead to
blindness however in exchange for the
risks dynamic vision is increased to the
utmost making surrounding movements look
dull and slow i think of it like the
world around and the opponent's attacks
are moving in slow motion giving you
much more time to respond and make the
right move it is undoubtedly one of my
favorite forms in the entire series it
allowed kano to get close to upper moon
2's neck so that with some help from
inosuke they could cut it off now yes
doma was poisoned and not at his best
but even so there is no way getting that
close to him against his will would ever
be easy especially with his op ice
powers and now we've come to level 3
breath styles once removed from sun
breathing these are the ones for the
most part that you are likely to see in
any generation of hashira the five main
ones include flame water wind thunder
and stone and we'll get a sixth one on
this level too but we'll get to why i
lean towards considering that one a bit
stronger than the five main ones you'll
also notice as we move up to the
strongest breath style sun breathing
that there are less tricks involved
which are incorporated as arguably a
form of compensation in the weaker
styles although all breath styles are
cool in their own way and i often enjoy
the trickiness of lower breath styles
you don't see stuff like insect
breathing's poison or sound breathing's
bombs being incorporated anymore it
actually gets more straightforward as we
get closer to sun breathing which is
just so strong when fully mastered it
doesn't seem to require any tricks just
pure ownage let's start with breath
style number eight wind breathing wind
breathing is used by the wind hashira
sanemi he learned it in the past with
his friend masachika kumeno who ended up
dying in a fight against a previous
lower rank one wind breathing is
associated with attacks that look
similar in appearance to whirlwinds
gusts typhoons and so on it's a very
offensive style and sun enemy uses a
standard sword it's not surprising that
inosuke's wild style branches off from
wind breathing because not only are sun
emi's attacks seemingly wild like a
tornado but he has even incorporated
genya's sword unexpectedly in the past
into a fight with upper moon one and he
held it with his foot not even with a
hand now demon slayers don't magically
generate their element in the world of
demon slayer like rengoku isn't actually
generating a flame tiger and giu isn't
actually generating water with his
slashes their normal sword attacks but
are just made to look cooler with those
added effects that overemphasize just
how much their sword swings look like
their elemental breath style like i
don't think i need to tell most people
that iguro isn't actually summoning a
snake when he attacks still i've seen it
said that some of sanemi's attacks are
different that he actually generates
wind from his swings and wind probably
would be the easiest element to generate
but again i'd lean on the side of all
significant damage he gives can probably
be boiled down to a physical sword slash
where the sword itself connected to the
target or even multiple very quick sword
slashes following one another the only
time this is not the case and deadly
elements or things are actually being
generated is with blood demon arts but
more on that later on in the video next
up let's look at breath style number
nine stone breathing stone breathing is
used by the strongest hashira gyome it's
associated with a very unique weapon
namely a nichiren spiked ball attached
to a long chain which is in turn
attached to an axe it's one of the more
long range weapons in the series and
gyome is able to wield it so
effortlessly because of his insane
strength in fact the mangaka ranked him
as the physically strongest of all the
hashira and called it scary how insanely
strong he is i usually think of gyoume
as someone who took stone breathing to
its pinnacle kind of how yuriji took sun
breathing to its pinnacle obviously he's
not on yuriji's level just the stone
breathing isn't as strong as sun
breathing but gyome took stone breathing
to a level that really impressed upper
moon 1 and even played the biggest role
in his defeat kokushibo said that gyomei
developed his physical form to the
utmost and he feels like it's been at
least 300 years since he's seen such a
great swordsman and that's before gyoume
even shows his demon's layer mark
another notable aspect is that gyome's
weapon has unusually high purity and
cannot be cut or broken by kokushibo it
said iron that absorbed that much
sunlight hadn't even been discovered in
the sengoku period when swordsmithing
was at its peak although gyome's
fighting style is more straightforward
than sun emis for the most part you know
when you adjust to his totally different
weapon gyome still finds himself needing
to think outside the box against
kokushibo while kokoshibo is fighting
sunemi gyome muichiro and genya he
doesn't really mess up until gyome
launches one of his rosary balls at
kokoshibo's hand which opens an
opportunity to deliver more significant
damage to the upper moon as we know sun
breathing yorichi wouldn't have needed a
rosary ball or even a team he could have
easily and straightforwardly defeated
kokushibo with sword skills as he did in
the past now let's enter what i view as
the big three of the main breathing
styles flame water and thunder and when
i say the big three i'm not saying they
are for sure stronger than wind and
stone when taken to their highest level
but there are a few things that stand
out about these three one is the fact
that we are introduced to former hashira
of these types and they are established
as having more of a tradition within the
world of demon slayer the other is that
at one point or another we see these
three styles take on the form of dragons
whether it be a lightning dragon water
dragon or flame dragon for kyojiro his
strongest attack takes the form of a
dragon in the movie and anime which
makes sense to me it appears to be a
purposeful change not just a change made
to add to the hype and it definitely
suggests to me that if he survived in
the manga we might have seen a flame
dragon from him there too just as we saw
a water dragon from gilu and the
lightning dragon from zenitsu why am i
singling out the styles that take the
forms of dragons you may ask well
because one dragons are often considered
to be the strongest creatures in myth
and therefore usually represent the
strongest level of power and two sun
breathing the strongest breath style is
known for taking the form of a dragon
and even has a move called dragon sun
halo head dance so yeah i just wanted to
point out something unique i noticed
about these three which may suggest that
they are on another level but does not
guarantee it so let's start with thunder
breathing breathing style number 10 for
the purposes of this video as we know
our boy zenitsu uses thunder breathing
and learned it from his former hashira
jigoro along with his senpai kaigaku
more on him later as most of us know
thunder breathing is associated with
extreme speed in fact the first form
thunderclap and flash is described as
being similar to lightning ripping
through the air it's zenitsu's go-to
move since it's the only one he knew and
could learn for a long time because i
need to focus so much on this one form
he kept improving on its execution until
he could perform first form thunderclap
and flash godspeed as with kano's
vermilion eye there can be consequences
this can only be used so many times
before zeitsu's legs are shot and
temporarily unusable but he always
recovered given enough time lastly there
is zaitsu's very hype self-created 7th
form called flaming thunder god and as
mentioned it takes the form of a
lightning dragon to add to its hype with
it he could out-speed new upper moon 6
kygaku despite the latter having demon
enhanced thunder breathing powers next
let's look at breath style number 11
water breathing of course tundra used it
along with former hashira sakonji sabito
makomo aoi and even murata but i think
most of us associate this breathing
style with the water hashira giu tomyoka
like thunder breathing water breathing
includes a standard nichiren katana the
swings often take the form of waves of
water but as mentioned sometimes they
take the form of a dragon gio used the
10th form constant flux when fighting
with muzon and his attack straight up
looked like he just unleashed shenron
from dragon ball notably this form gets
stronger and stronger by building up
momentum with each rotation making it an
especially cool and powerful move i'll
also mention guillo's own personal
creation 11th form dead com the user
seemingly clears their mind and ceases
all unnecessary movement then when the
attacks come like rui's threads the user
cuts them so fast that the movement is
practically invisible to the eye it sort
of reminds you of ultra instinct getting
into a state where your body is ready to
respond for you cutting the amount of
time it takes to react this form is not
actually an impenetrable defense though
and someone at a high enough level like
akasa can break through it next let's
look at breath style number 12 flame
breathing not fire breathing but flame
breathing we're told the exact wording
is very important probably because
fire's associated with the fire god
which is associated with sun breathing
rather than flame breathing still the
similarities of flame and fire are not
lost on us and it makes flame breathing
feel special because of its closeness to
sun breathing known flame breathers
include shinjuro rengoku kyojiro rengoku
and for a time mitsuri but kyojiro is
definitely the main dude we think about
when we think about flame breathing
notably there was a dude with rengoku's
hair when yorichi first taught people
breathing styles so flame was one of the
first and then goku's family was there
from the beginning and managed to pass
it down without fail for hundreds of
years it's probably not a coincidence
that ngoku's flame breathing sword
sometimes called red and other times
reddish orange depending on who you ask
is closest to color to the ultimate
bright red sword used by sun breathers
and then as i mentioned in the movie and
anime they changed the final attack to
include a flame dragon which i think is
probably what the mangaka would have
wanted if she could go back and change
the beginning knowing the end and how
significant the dragons would become so
yeah although not sun breathing it's
definitely one of the closest to it
based off of the idea of fire and flames
based off of the color of the blade
based off of the dragon attacks so it
comes as no surprise to me that rengoku
was one of the strongest hashira and did
so well against akaza and keep in mind
this was without awakening a demon
slayer mark then we move on to breath
style number 13 moon breathing a tricky
style to be sure the breathing style
relationship chart puts moon breathing
as one removed from sun breathing just
like flame thunder water stone and wind
in my view it deserves a little bit
extra respect because the moon always
comes off as an equal partner to the sun
in mythology and depending on how the
mangaka wanted to do it water could have
even been made to branch off from moon
because of the moon's connection to
waves and all that however i put in the
same category as the others level 3
because the mangaka made it simply
branch off from sun breathing like the
others still there's a caveat there
because i do want to give it some bonus
points based off of yorichi and
kokoshibo's backstory in the backstory
although yorichi always surpassed his
brother michikatsu tsugikuni aka
kokoshibo michikatsu once said to him
that no skilled warriors were comparable
to them too he went on to say and i
quote the prospects for the succession
of the breathing art are dismal the
perfected techniques would die out end
quote which to me sounds like that in
this old golden age of breathing styles
where a lot of techniques were seemingly
perfected moon breathing was only second
to sun breathing but we won't get into
moon breathing forms just yet because we
don't actually see proper moon breathing
we see blood demon art enhanced moon
breathing which brings us to our next
level level 2 breath styles once removed
from sun breathing plus blood demon art
enhancements you may argue that there
should have been more levels where i
could have placed demon enhanced insect
breathing and so on but since we only
saw demon enhanced thunder and moon
breathing i thought it didn't make much
sense to speculate about how the other
styles would have looked if we combined
them with a blood demon heart so let's
start with breath style number 14 demon
thunder breathing as the opposite of
zanitsu kaigaku learned thunder
breathing forms two to six but couldn't
learn the first one that zenitsu honed
so much despite this after becoming a
demon kaigaku claims he surpassed
thunder breathing and there is a reason
i put this demon breathing style ahead
of normal thunder breathing kaigaku's
blood demon art actually lets him
manifest electricity or black lightning
to enhance his thunder breathing forms
an interesting detail revealed in a data
book is that he uses a sword made out of
his flesh like okushibo which comes with
benefits like being able to regenerate
if it's broken or being able to channel
his blood demon art through it more
effectively the blood demon art
increases the damage sharpness and range
of kagaku's attacks while his
demonization makes him even faster than
he was before which is notable because
users of thunder breathing are known for
speed already kagaku remarks that his
attacks don't just cut the flesh but
also burn it he further comments that
any slashing attacks zenitsu takes will
continue to rent his flesh aka rip apart
his flesh the electricity burns into the
opponent's eyes and body thus it doesn't
just burn at the moment of impact but
like poison it has after effects and you
might be thinking yeah but he loses to
zanetsu and that's true but it comes
back to the distinction between
individual fighters rather than the
distinction between breath styles
seizure is more skilled at this point in
the story even going so far as to create
his own thunder form flaming thunder god
that's fast enough to cut off kaigaku's
head without him even being able to see
it it's a crazy detail and we should all
let it sink in and even then as kagaku
mentions they were both going to die
zaintsu had no more energy left and he
was going to fall to his death but
luckily you should was there to save him
from the fall and save him from the
spreading of kagaku's blood demon art in
his body furthermore yushiro mentions
that kaigaku was inexperienced he hadn't
mastered his techniques and abilities he
says if the fight happened one year
later kaigaku would have probably killed
zenitsu immediately so given all that
imagine how strong zenitsu would have
been using demon enhanced thunder
breathing imagine how powerful and fast
a technique like flaming black thunder
god would have been as it took the form
of a black lightning dragon attacking
the enemy yeah this black thunder
breathing definitely has some insane
potential then we get to breath style
number 15 demon moon breathing used by
upper moon 1 kokushibo like with kaigaku
kokushibo uses a sword made of his demon
flesh but kokoshibo had way more
experience mastering his style remember
when yusuru said that if kaigaku had
another year saints it would have been
toast while kokushibo had centuries he
can straight up change the shape of his
sword to increase its reach and its
unpredictability his blood demon art is
called crescent moon blades and as the
name suggests it allows countless
crescent moon blades to appear from his
sword and slashes just like utero's
bloodsicles these crescent blades travel
through the air and will cut anything
they come into contact with giving
kokoshibo long range attacks despite the
fact that he's a swordsman the other
tricky aspect of this demon moon
breathing style is that the countless
crescent moon blades are chaotic and are
always changing in length and size
making them practically impossible to
predict and very difficult to avoid when
he increases the size of his sword and
makes a branch like kokoshibo can
unleash attacks like moon dragon
ringtail again notice the dragon there
which is a very long range and deadly
attack the skilled wind hashra sanemi
thinks that he can't get close enough to
cut his neck after kokoshibo launches
this attack and he even comments on how
he needs to use all of his strength just
to dodge such attacks since kokoshibo
lived for so long he was able to create
and master at least a shocking 16 forms
of moon breathing some notable forms
include the 14th form which creates a
violent vortex of crescent blades and
the 16th form which allows him to rain
down crescent blades on his opponents
each point of impact is so powerful that
it destroys the floor and i think that
about covers moon breathing there is
clearly a reason that it took the
strongest hashita gyome two of the other
strongest hashira sanemi and muichiro
and even genya who had the power to
absorb kokoshibo's great power and use
it against him to defeat this breathing
style finally that leads us to level 1
the final and strongest breath style
which is funny because it was the first
created of course i'm talking about sun
breathing breath style number 16 for the
purposes of this video we know yurichi
the strongest demonstrator in history
used this style and passed it down to
tundra's ancestor sumiyoshi and
eventually worked its way down to
tundra's dad and then tanjiro in the
form of the dance of the fire god
yorichi used the initial 12 forms to
wreck muzon and i mean like
embarrassingly crush him and he even
gave him ptsd during this encounter but
scared and shocked muzon still managed
to survive by suddenly bursting his body
open with incredible force he scattered
his body into 1 800 pieces and yurichi
got an unbelievable 1 500 but the
remaining 300 that escaped were enough
for muslim to eventually regenerate
yorichi as an old man proved to be far
superior to demon kokoshibo too but he
died of old age standing up before he
could finish off kokoshibo after his
encounter with muzon yorichi created the
so-called 13th form as a means to kill
muzon which consisted of actually
repeating forms 1 through 12 over and
over again while increasing the speed
and accuracy against muzon tundra hoped
he could keep it up until the sun came
out and finished the job however he
hadn't mastered sun breathing to the
extent yurichi had and he needed
significant help from the other demon
slayers as mentioned this breath style
can also take the form of a fire dragon
as we see when tundra uses the move sun
halo dragon against muzon sun breathing
is also associated with a black blade
that turns bright red during combat and
this bright red blade is super effective
against demons and significantly slows
down their regeneration near the end of
the series the most skilled slayers even
non-sun breathers are able to similarly
turn their blade bright red reaffirming
the fact that it is the strongest color
you can reach what else is there to say
except that yorichi sun breathing was so
strong so overpowered that he burned
muzon on a cellular level and even after
hundreds of years and muzon's insane
level of regeneration the wounds appear
on muslin's body again during the final
battle helping the demon slayer see
where his weak points are and that is it
for all 16 breath styles ranked for weak
is the strongest hope you enjoyed this
video and i hope the level thing wasn't
too confusing i'm realizing now that
level 1 being the strongest might be a
bit confusing but just don't view it as
your rpg character leveling up and it
should make sense i like the idea of one
being the strongest and working down to
it let me know your thoughts on all this
in the comments i encourage you to let
me know if you agree or disagree with
this list and why the goal is always to
start a discussion with these videos
also let me know in the comments what
your favorite breath style is and what
kind of breathing style you wish you saw
but didn't in the series if you did like
the video you know what to do channel
the sunbreather within and smash that
like button with no mercy remember
smashing that like button is your ichi
energy and passing is scared moves on
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and this
is critical hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future demonstrator videos and
updates and while you wait for the next
demonstrator video to drop feel free to
check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos on all demon moons hashira and
much more link to that is in the
description as i'm finishing this script
i look forward to seeing how long this
video actually ends up being because the
research slash writing phase definitely
took a while and i feel like it's gonna
be a pretty long one we'll see but
that's another reason you should smash
that like button if you enjoyed the
video because it encourages me to make
more of these longer ones that take more
work and yeah now that i recorded up to
this point i feel like i may be losing
my voice a bit but it's all good anyways
that's it for this one happy new year
since this will hopefully be done around
that time wishing you and all your loved
ones the best in 2022 and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you